There aren't many pneumatic
tube systems left in the world.
They used to be...
well, not everywhere,
but a hundred years ago,
most major western cities
would have a few of them for
sending messages around,
either within a building
or between buildings.
At one point, New York had
27 miles of pneumatic tubes
between post offices.
And you can still
see them sometimes,
in American
drive-through banks,
or in a few hospitals for
quickly moving samples around.
Last year, I visited one
in Canada that's used for
transmitting small amounts
of radioactive stuff
for medical therapy.
I know of only one place,
however,
that sends food through them.
This is C1 Espresso in
Christchurch, New Zealand,
and about 10 years ago,
they installed a brand new
set of pneumatic tubes.
- Customer places an order
at the counter,
which will then get sent
through to the kitchen.
From there, the chefs
can open it up,
see what they need to make,
if it's a meal that goes
inside a pneumatic tube,
we've got a map on the wall,
our chefs will then know
where that customer is sitting
and which tube to send it to.
We're a wee bit limited to
what we can put through them.
Soup's never a good option.
Burgers, fries will be
packaged in these tubes,
stainless steel, food grade.
We do throw a can of beer
through them every now and then,
so long as people don't mind
getting a bit fizzed up
when it arrives at their table.
But otherwise, we get our
bakers to specially make
a torpedo-shaped burger.
Most companies don't have
fancy see-through tubes.
They were made in Germany
and imported in,
especially for us.
- As restaurant gimmicks go,
I really like this.
There are a few competitors
out there in the world
that use things like
conveyor belts or miniature
rollercoaster tracks,
but here, your food isn't open
to cold air as it travels.
But I've been here filming
for an hour or two now,
and most of the people here
are not ordering the menu items
that go through
the pneumatic tubes.
They're ordering the rest of
the menu, or the coffees.
These tubes attract the tourists,
but the repeat customers are locals,
and they're here for actually
good coffee and food.
Turns out that a cafe like this
can't survive without
actually being good.
- We've been around for 11 years now.
We have a roastery where we roast
our own coffee in-house
and create our own blend,
called C1000.
The pneumatic tubes were
set up from day one.
The main issues we have
around maintenance
is the actual tubes themselves,
wear and tear on those.
- There we go.
Oops.
Five second rule.
- They create friction and
get stuck within the system.
Everything else, touch wood,
seems to work relatively well...
...most of the time.
We're really lucky, the new
Christchurch Hospital,
about a kilometer
down the road,
still uses a
pneumatic tube system.
There's a company in Auckland
that's able to come down
and do repairs and maintenance
on ours when they're down
looking after the
hospital as well.
One of the main issues we have,
especially in a busy kitchen
when we've got a full cafe,
tube doesn't get closed properly,
decides with the vibrations
to wiggle itself open,
chips go everywhere and then
the tube actually stops
in the roof of the
middle of the cafe.
If it's not too stuck,
we'll try and push some
more air through
to see if it'll
unjam itself.
Second option being,
we've got a unit that
sucks it back
the way it came.
Third option, which is my
least favorite option,
is we have to cut them
out of the ceiling
at the end of the day.
You hope it's near a join
that's already been cut.
Maybe happens once
or twice a year.
...fingers crossed.
- Of course, I did ask if
I could put my GoPro camera
through the pneumatic tubes
to get pictures of
the food's journey.
And they said yes!